ces temps que jean ville petite commune
d'ars et loire 1825 habitants n'avaient
plus de librairie cette ouverture était
attendue espérée et les amoureux des
livres en tôt fait de trouver ici leur
marque et de son réjouir
je suis très heureuse qui est des livres
à nouveau disponible à janville oui
papeterie en plus et puis il y avait une
volonté de créer du lien je crois donc
c'est sûr quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur
donc très contente cette librairie qui
ouvre enfin dans un endroit où il n'y a
que des supermarchés dans lesquelles il
ya des rayons livres bien évidemment
toujours assez limité c'est une
satisfaction
ancien magasin de décoration la nouvelle
librairie prête à la flânerie avec un
toit jeunes fournir sur le pouce une
carterie et beaucoup de livres des
livres pour tous les publics et pour
tous les goûts
demain j'ai mes trois enfants qui
arrivent alors je vous dis que les adore
en plus ces ateliers les jeux de société
marie thérèse parrot est une fille du
pays et ancien gestionnaire grands
comptes pour des constructeurs
automobiles à paris à la suite d'une
reconversion professionnelle
l'appel de la beauce a été le plus fort
la chance d'avoir un projet qui était
validée à tous les niveaux et qui était
reconnu comme un bon projet j'ai moi
même suivi une formation de libraires
puisque c'est une reconversion ce qui me
concerne donc j'ai dû faire une
formation complète pour moi c'est le
début d'une d'un beau livre qui va
s'écrire au fil du temps et puis
j'attends que tous les clients qui
rentrent dans la librairie m'aide à
écrire les autres pages
la nouvelle libraire fourmis déjà de
projets organiser des débats et des
rencontres avec des auteurs créer du
lien social
le public en redemande